bonjour marie les torpilles bonjour
monsieur vialleton bonjour aux
auditrices et auditeurs de martine
qu'une première vous êtes conseillère
exécutive en charge du développement
économique de la martinique merci d'être
avec nous alors que la plénière de
l'assemblée s'est achevée vers 23 heures
il en sera remanié torpille est ce que
vous allez mieux on vous a vu très en
colère avant-hier quand vous avez
entendu max orville le président du
modem dans ce studio dire que cette
septième ne fait pas dans la plus grande
transparence
quand elle demande par exemple l'état
rachète des dettes fiscales et sociales
de l'hôtellerie oui oui je vais mieux de
toutes les façons vous savez quand j'ai
entendu les propos de max orville j'ai
trouvé simple lamentable surtout que
j'estimais que quand même que max
orville était quelqu'un de sérieux je
veux je voudrais vraiment très bon fin
pour ce qu'il dit bon je voudrais
comprennent quand même une minute je
dirais pour bien expliquer ce qui se
passe parce que vous savez à force de
dire certains propos les gens après
mélange tout et la démarche qui est
entamée peu est entachée non il a on a
on connaît le constat aujourd'hui de
décider de l'hôtellerie chez nous un
hôtel fermé chaque année on a perdu plus
de 2000 148 chambres
c'est à dire un tiers de notre capacité
d'accueil
il fallait faire quelque chose et c'est
vrai que la démarche qui avaient été
entamées depuis 2013 a été conclu par le
président marie jeanne en faisant enfin
quand on faisait un vote
donc ça ne s'est pas passe en catimini
en faisant un vote catalan en faisait un
vote à l'assemblée à l'assemblée
plénière qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'il ya
qu'est ce qu'il y à vraiment dans cette
mesure c'est que d autres les hôtels qui
ont besoin d'être rénovées ils ont
besoin de financement ils ne peuvent pas
aller sur des fonds dédiés des fonds
européens dédiés
parce qu'elle croule sous les dettes
parce qu'elles courent sur les dettes
fiscales et sociales
non non vous allez dd tu risques aller
sociale dont vous ne pouvez pas
emprunter des fonds européens et donc
pas couplées avec des prêts bancaires
donc la vidéo devant la relève des de
racheter ses dettes
aujourd'hui ce développement de racheter
les dettes donc des hôteliers qui le
demandent et de pouvoir comme ça proposé
à l'autre
et parce que ce n'est pas un cadeau
proposé à l'automne et un remboursement
à long terme
donc ce n'est pas un effacement de la
dette ce n'est pas un cadeau c'est un
prêt à long terme
que fait la ctn dans cette affaire vous
voyez je vous ai parlé de du dispositif
josé pas parler de la ctm la 7e n'a pas
d'engagement direct par contre la 7e
venait en garantie des prêts donc c'est
parce que la salle à ces termes on a
compris et donc le président marie
jeanne a compris qu'il fallait qu'on se
mobilise tous pour sauver notre
hôtellerie mais vous comprenez quand
même que monsieur tout le monde madame
son sont souhaitables et par la question
tout le monde sait qu'un vice président
de l'assemblée dans un groupe qui porte
son nom et qui a des billes dans le
secteur il s'agit de yan monplaisir
oui mais enfin son vrai paraître petit
normal on attendait l'hôtellerie
l'hôtellerie c'est d'abord ceux qui sont
le plus en difficulté et à des gros
total mais ya beaucoup de petits hôtels
et de moyens hôtels bon ce que moi je
pourrais dire sur ça
le groupe monplaisir notamment yan
monplaisir ils ont acheté deux hôtels en
grande difficulté si ces jeux si ce
groupe est donc cette famille n'avait
pas investi à ce moment là ce serait
deux au tamis jeune originaire du sud
qu'à son âge n'ont plus de 400 emplois
plus de 400 emplois qui auraient eux qui
auraient disparu aujourd'hui on veut
taper et directement ou sournoisement
sur des gens qui investissent dans leur
pays
je pense qu'il faut qu'on arrête nos
points communs qu'on prenne de la
hauteur on fait notre position n'était
pas fait pour pour le groupe monplaisir
cette disposition était fait avant tout
pour la petite hôtellerie et la moyenne
hôtellerie donc les gens c'est sûr que
quand vous êtes quelque part et en plus
que vous vous osez pouvoir vous
impliquant politique on veut
effectivement vous vous prêter de
mauvaises intentions
ça permet de clarifier la situation
qu'il faut que ça s'arrête et que ce
n'est pas parce que des gens à dire du
secteur économique et veulent s'investir
en politique qu'ils doivent être
suspecte rien à torpiller votre équipe
est attendu au tournant sur de
véritables propositions pour booster le
développement martinique en début
d'année je me souviens de cette
interview de bernard edwards le
président du medef qui disait dans
france antilles que la septème pouvait
soutenir l'activité
la 7e à la cape
c'était financière d'investir mais il
faut lancer la machine c'est ce que
disait bernard edwards en année où est
ce que la machine est dans les starting
blocks est-ce que ça va commencer
l'opposition dit qu' elle ne devra rien
venir savez l'opposition est dans son
rôle de dire qu'elle ne voit rien venir
on a encore eu quelques échanges hier
lors de la plénière
et encore on dit quand on voit tout ce
qui se passe tout ce que nous votons
toutes les dispositions qui sont prises
les les engagements qui sont faits le
budget le budget de 2016 a été a été
consommé on ne peut pas dire que la
classe était menacée juste du temps pour
que les choses soient mortes et neuf il
a de toute façon on quand on dit qu'il
faut du temps c'est pas parce qu'il faut
du temps que nous ne faisons rien nous
faisons mais en même temps il faut
effectivement s'organiser ce qui a été
fait en 2016 l'organisation n'est pas
terminé on continue encore en 2017 tout
le monde sait très bien aujourd'hui est
d'accord pour le reconnaître que la
gouvernance que nous avons n'est pas le
meilleur modèle qu'il fallait mais ce
n'est pas pour autant que nous faisons
avec et que nous avançons
ce n'est pas pour autant que les
décisions sans risque israël risque qui
tournait en cas d'heures sur le bord du
chemin
le très puissant ne pas en un coup de
baguette magique régler tous les
problèmes
je parlais par exemple hier du problème
de la commande publique
oui c'est vrai qu'il a fallu relancer
mais cette commande publique a été
relancé donc le btp a vu certains
marchés donc cet attribut et on a pu
attribuer certains marchés mais pour
pouvoir lancer de gros marchés il faut
qu'il y ait des préparations avant vous
ne venez pas dans une institution et
lancer des gros marchés en deux trois
mois ce n'est pas vrai si tout à fait si
vous le faites c'est que si vous le
faites c'est que il y avait déjà les
études qui était fait
il y avait déjà du travail qui était
fait sur sim sur ses chantiers
on a trouvé des chantiers qui n'était
pas commencer ou à peine commencé ou
terminé enfin nous n'avons pas trouvé de
quoi le relancer la machine tout de
suite donc c'est tout un travail qui est
fait avec toutes les équipes avec les
personnel avec toutes les équipes
techniques et hier daniel marie-sainte
s'est expliqué sur cette partie comment
c'était pas simple et que les choses ne
viennent pas comme ça matip se faire
dans une tribune qu'elle a consacré la
mainmise du grand ensemble et pumba
pillant chance sur l'école on y
reviendra dans une autre émission avec
la nomination des conseillers
territoriaux mais catherine conconne
l'ancien vice président de la région est
élue d'opposition pmn écrit tout le
monde râle dans son petit coin tous les
secteurs économiques sans même avoir
plus de souffle pour hurler pour dire
non à cette chape de plomb tous
terrorisés se taire se cachent ils se
sont résignés à la manière des
prisonnières y ait chaque jour qui passe
sur leur calendrier
vous connaissez ce sont les propos de
catherine conconne elle va faire dans le
catastrophisme mais en fait à l'époque
où elle était où elle était aux affaires
les entreprises était déjà dans un état
lamentable où il y avait en fin de
compte surtout le fait du prince et on
ne donnait coke aux amis et aux copains
non enfin je pense qu'il faut arrêter
aujourd'hui les choses sont faites déjà
en plus grande transparence
les laits je dirais les dispositions
sont prises certaines mesures sont
prises moi je regarde aujourd'hui
comment nous avons pu donner un certain
espoir une certaine lisibilité
visibilité aux entreprises lors du
dernier salon de rendez-vous des
entrepreneurs aux que nous avons tenu à
madiana au niveau de comme je disais au
niveau de la commande publique les les
choses sont sur les rails
partout je dirai où nous nous avons nous
avons oeuvré pendant deux ans 2016 et
nous continuons en 2017
nous mettons de l'ordre dé nous et nous
engageons quand vous regardez au niveau
des fonds européens
chaque à chaque séance de à chaque
séance plénière il y a des dossiers qui
sont validées qui sont votées
donc on ne peut pas dire alors il y à un
phrasé oui ça va de plus en plus vite
savent c'est vrai que il a fallu re je
dirais réorganiser ce service qui
aujourd'hui a l'air de fonctionner et
encore des ralentissements au niveau du
feader
mais je dis c'est une grosse machine ou
là dessus il a fallu véritablement se
pencher pour l'organiser et aujourd'hui
je pense que on ne peut pas dire qu'on
ne produit pas et on le démontre on le
demande à chaque année lumière avec tous
les dossiers que nous validons nous
produisons aujourd'hui les choses
seraient bien nous attendons nous
attendons ce fameux plan territorial du
développement économique sommes nous
dans les temps ça s'appelle marion le
schéma régional du développement
économique de l'innovation et de
l'internationalisme sera alors au top on
n'est pas alors on peut on peut pas dire
qu'on est en retard en fin de compte la
loi notre demande est donc à chaque
région a au moment de son renouvellement
d'adopter ce schéma de développement
pour dans l'année qui suivait donc le
renouvellement de la de la région donc
dans toutes les régions étaient
renouvelés les élections se sont tenues
en décembre 2015 donc pour l'année 2016
il fallait produire ce schéma mais aussi
bien chez nous avec la fusion de la du
conseil général et du conseil général
donc je dirais y avait d'autres
préoccupations d'organisation écrite est
prioritaire mais aussi dans les régions
de france et avait 7 vous savez qu'on
ait passé un homme plus réduit de
régions il y avait aussi des fusions
entre orlando qui fait que la majorité
des régions ont demandé un délai
supplémentaire donc un ce document qui
devait être fait pour le 31 décembre va
être certainement sortir on pense que
non le sortir à la fin du premier
trimestre 2010 est que ce sera nous
avons bien là nous ce sera en fin de
compte ce schéma va donner les
orientations en termes des deux
entreprises en termes de démarche à
l'international en termes de dimanche
vers l'innovation en termes d'économie
sociale et solidaire
donc c'est tout un jeu des restes je
dirai ce sont l'ensemble des mesures qui
devront être prises pour organiser le
territoire surtout pour mettre de la
compétence et de la cohérence entre tous
les acteurs économiques
merci d'avancé sur internet nous marier
de torpilles on rappelle que vous êtes
conseillère exécutive en charge du
développement économique à l'assemblée
de martinique aux collectivités merci
consécutif